[موسيقى]
اوقات اعزائي المشاهدين كل عام وانتم بخير
بمناسبه حلول العام الجديد هذه بانوراما
يقدمه
في لبنان عن نقل زعيم ميليشيات حزب الله
حسن نصر الله الى المستشفى والبعض يشير
الى انه في حاله حرجه وبالعنايه المركزه
فمن يخلف نصر الله في حال المرض او
الابتعاد عن المنصب
بعد الاجراءات الروسيه الصينيه في
مواجهتها مقال في مجله فرن افرز الامريكيه
يطرح سؤالا حول عقوبات واشنطن هل انتهى
عصرها ولم تعد فعاله مثل ما كانت في
الماضي
كريستيانو رونالدو واضخم صفقه في تاريخ
الكره العالميه بعد انتقاله للنصر السعودي
ما هي العوائد المتوقعه رياضيا واقتصاديا
من هذه الصفقه
في لبنان تداولت وسائل الاعلام المحليه
خبر مرضي الامين العام لحزب الله حسن نصر
الله الذي كان محل اهتمام كثيرين على
مواقع التواصل عن اداره العلاقات
الاعلاميه في حزب الله قال بان حسن نصر
الله تعرض لوعكه صحيه بسيطه بعد اصابته
بالانفلونزاما ادى لالغاء احد خطاباته الى
ان نصر الله سيكون حاضر لالقائي لكلمه يوم
الثلاثاء المقبل في الذكر الثالثه لاغتيال
قائد منشيه فيلق القدس بالحرس الثوري
الايراني
قالت وسائل الاعلام اللبنانيه ان اصابه
حسن نصر الله التي ادخلته لمستشفى الرسول
الاعظم هي جلطه دماغيه ثانيه وهنا رجح
مراقبنا للتطورات الحاصله انه هو في حال
مرض نصر الله او ابتعاده فان القرار
الاخير في تعيين خليفه الله يعود للنظام
الايراني وليس للبنيه التنظيميه لحزب الله
سؤالنا ايران هي صاحبه القرار في وضع
خليفه
للامين العام لحزب الله وتحديدا المرشد
الاعلى عليخه من ايه ومن ابرز الشخصيات
التي تم تداوله اسمائها هي هاشم صفي الدين
رئيس المجلس التنفيذي في حزب الله وهو
قريب للامين العام للحزب وايضا نائب
الامين العام في حزب الله نعيم قاسم وهو
شخصيه ليست حزبيه وانما معمره
[موسيقى]
معي من المدينه المنوره
السيد محمد علي ابدا معكم ما حقيقه الوضع
الصحي للسيد حسن نصر الله
نعم السلام عليكم وعلى سائر المشاهدين
والمستمعين واتمنى للجميع العام الجديد ان
يكون حاملا معه المحبه والتسامح
والعافيه والامن والامان والاستقرار
بالحقيقه ما يعاني منه السيد حسن نصر الله
ليس بمرض عضال او بحيث ان يكون مرض واقعي
حقيقي يؤدي الى الوفاه انما بطبيعه الوجود
الذي فرض عليه منذ عام 2006 يعني ما يقارب
من 16 سنه الى اليوم
فهو
ياخذ الهواء الاصطناعي ولا يمكن ان يعيش
في الهواء الطلق مما ادى الى مشكله حقيقيه
في التنفس والى ضيق نفس حقيقه وواقعا مما
سبب ذلك مرارا وتكرارا وهذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يتم الاعلان عن هذه الحاله
التي لا تعد حرجه او حقيقه خطيره انما كما
قلت وبينت نتيجه عدم تعرضه او استنشاطه
للهواء النقي وعدم وجوده في اماكن مفتوحه
وهو مضطر ان يكون في اماكن مغلقه وان يكون
تحت رحمه الهواء الاصطناعي هذا كله سبب
حساسيه همم له بحيث انه لا يستطيع التنفس
عاده والتهابات بالرئه التهابات الى هذا
الحد وليس اكثر نعم نعم استاذ احمد عياش
همم ضيفي من المدينه المنوره يقول لنا وضع
نصر الله ليس في حاله حرجه همم الاعلام
المقرب من الحزب قال انه اصيب بالانفلونزا
اا طبعا اعلام لبناني قال ان وضعه حرج وهو
موضوع في العنايه المركزه ما المعلومات
التي وصلتك عن حقيقه وضع نصر الله
مساء الخير استاذ صهيب يضيفك الكريم وشكرا
على الاستضافه وانا اعتقد يعني كما يعني
اشاره ضيفك الكريم سيد الحسيني
فيما يتعلق بالوضعيه التي يعيش فيها السيد
نصر الله ولكن الذهاب الى استنتاج النهائي
بالقول ان يعني وضعه خارج او غير حرج انا
اعتقد الامر محاط بالسوريه تامه نحن نتحدث
عن رسول الاعظم الذي هو قلعه مقبره
وتجري فيه امور كثيره ولا يستطيع المرء
الوصول الى اثنى المعلومات ولكن على كل
حال
انا شخصيا واتابع الاعلام طبعا يعني اعتقد
ان الاعلان عن ارجاء كلمته التي كانت
مقرره الجمعه الماضي
بشكل
بان هناك انفلونزا ربما هذا الامر حصل
بطريقه لم توحي الكثيرين بان هناك يعني
ثقه كامله بان الموضوع يتعلق بالانفلونزا
وايضا مضاف الى ذلك وهذا ما يجب التوقف
عنده هذا البيان الذي صدر على العلاقات
الاعلاميه لحزب الله نهار الجمعه الماضي
واعلن عن ارجاء اطلاله نصر الله في ذلك
الحين قال انه سيطل الثلاثاء الثلاثاء
يعني بعد 48 ساعه من اجل الحديث عن مناسبه
لها علاقه بقسم سليماني الذكر السنويه
لاغتياله طبعا هنا السؤال المشروع لماذا
حدد الثلاثاء بانه هل هو يشفى بمعنى
سيجتاز هذه الازمه لها علاقه بالانفلونزا
ويكون الثلاثاء حاضرا نحن امام مرحله هي
48 ساعه فقط لكن عندما يحدد موعد بهكذا
بهكذا شكل وكان هناك من يقول نحن نضمن ان
هذا المرض حصل مرض سيتولى او سيولى خلال
الايام
الثلاثاء المقبل
الامور تفرض يعني عمليه تامل فيما يتعلق
بهذا الامر صحيح هنا اعتقد القضيه محاطه
بعلامات السهام يعني يجب عدم اسقاط اي
فرضيه ونحن في نهايه المطاف استاذ صهيب
نحن بشر كلنا معرضون لكل شيء وبالتالي يجب
ان لا نضع هذه الفرضيات جانبا ربما هناك
يعني الكثير من المحاكاه او ربما من
التوترات السياسيه في لبنان ما تجعل
احيانا قول الحقائق امرا يعني يخضع
للمساءله او يطرح الامور من زاويه يعني
المواجهات السياسيه وهو الامر ليس كذلك
وبالتالي يجب التعامل بكل جديه مع هذه
المعطيات وكما قلت لك 48 ساعه فقط تفصلنا
عما اذا كان هذا الامر
نعم
في المدينه المنوره كما قال الاستاذ احمد
عياش نحن في النهايه بشر وبغض النظر عن اي
تجاذبات يعني في النهايه بتجرد السؤال
يطرح منذ فتره حتى قبل غياب حسن نصر الله
عن خطاب الجمعه وتاجيله الى يوم الثلاثاء
هل هناك خليفه
لحسن نصر الله من سيخلف حسن نصر الله
الغاء
نعم ليست بالمعنى الحرفي خليفه انما حزب
الله من يتوهم بانه حزب محلي فهو خاطئ
ومشتبه حزب الله هو اصبح منظمه وليس
اقليميه فحست بل منظمه دوليه تخضع بالقرار
الى القياده الايرانيه وهذا ليس سرا او
نفشي السر بهذا الاتجاه نحن نعلم بان
الامانه العامه لحزب الله بدات مع في
الثمانينات مع السيد ابراهيم امين السيد
وانتقلت الى الشيخ صبحي طفيلي ومن بعده
الى السيد عباس الموسوي وصولا الى السيد
حسن نصر الله في اي حال من الاحوال هناك
مجلس الشورى القرار وهو فيه من لبنان
ولبنا وايضا من ايران
وهناك القرار الذي يحدد من يكون همم امين
عام لحزب الله ينبغي ان يكون للسيد
الخامنئي كلام الفصل في هذا الاتجاه
وليس طبعا بان المرشح الاوفى همم حظا بهذا
الاتجاه هو السيد هاشم صفي الدين لعده
اسباب ممكن اطرحها ان احللها ان نعطي
المعطيات عنها خاصه بانه اليوم هو في
مرتبه او في توصيف همم مجلس التنفيذي في
حزب الله سوره التنفيذ وهو بالتالي الشخص
الثاني المهيم هذا امر جدا مهم وهو لديه
اطلاع كامل على الوحدات والمراكز والفروع
وكل الاقسام داخل حزب الله التنظيميه بل
وهو يحرقها ومسؤول عنها وبالتالي قضيه من
يكون بعد نصر الله هذا الامر سهل ويسير
لان كما قلت وبينت المساله ان حزب الله
ليس كحزب محلي ممكن ان يكون هناك انتخابات
او لا بد ان يكون هناك قرار واضح
ساعود اليك في مساله القرار القراءه
القراءه القرار من ايران يعني طيب ساعود
اليك من هذه النقطه ولكن دعني اتوسع مع
الاستاذ احمد عياش هل تتفق مع سيد الحسيني
بان هاشم صفي الدين هو يعني المرشح الاوفر
حظا لكي يختار خلفا لحسن نصر الله
تمام تماما انا اوافق تماما مع السيد
الحسيني في ما قاله السيد هاشم صفي الدين
هو الذي سيكون ال- اا يعني مرشح انه يخلف
نصر الله اذا اذا حصل اذا صلى ما يعيق
بقائه في هذا المنصب لماذا لكن اود ان
اضيف همم اضيف معطي ربما يعني يكمل الصوره
التي بدات السيد الحسين
لم يخرج ولم يصل الى هذا الموقع الذي هو
في عن طريق التراتبيات التقليديه في حزب
الله بمعنى ان يبدا ال همم الفرد من ادنى
المستويات ومن ثم يصبح في موقع المتقدم
هذا ما حصل مع السيد نصر الله شخصيه بمعنى
هو بدا في يعني كان مراهقا عندما انتسب
الى هذا الفرح يعني
خلف السيد الموسوي
تماما انما فيما يتعلق بالسيد صفي الدين
عندما يعني اصبح في الواجهه واصبح له هذا
الموقع
هناك هناك معلومات نحن لا نتحدث عن
تحليلات معلومات تقول انه اتى خارج السياق
التقليدي بالوصول الى هذا الموقع بمعنى لم
يتدرج في يعني في الهرم يعني الهرم
المسؤوليات فيما يتعلق بحزب الله ولكنه
اتى بنفوز الحارس السوري الايراني مباشره
السياق التقليدي للحزب بل هو بتسكيه
مباشره من ايران عبر الحرس الثوري
هذا اهم عيار في الاختيار
[موسيقى]
تماما
وهذا ما يجعل السيد او الشيخ نعيم قاسم في
مرتبه التاليه باي معنى انه لم ياتي في
هذا السياق المتدرج اتى هو عفوا بالسياق
متدرج ولكن فيما يتعلق بالسيد صافي الدين
جاء من خلال هذا النفوس نحن نعلم انه حزب
الله في نهايه اللطاف هو وفصيل هو تاب
لفريق القدس في الحرس الثوري الايراني نحن
نتحدث عن مؤسس قائمه هي التي تمنع هذا
الشخص او ذلك نفوزا يتفوق على اي رغبات
المحليه في لبنان في سوريا في العراق في
اليمن في اي مكان
لايران هذا هذا النفوس وبالتالي السيد
صافي الدين اذا حصل ما حصل اعتقد انه
سيكون الامين العام لحزب الله نعم سيد
الحسيني بين هاشم صفي الدين ونعيم قاسم هل
هناك صراع
لا ابدا في حزب الله لا يوجد اقطع واجزم
صراعات من هذا النوع بس اسمح لي ان اصحح
بعض المسائل التي جاءت من الاستاذ الكبير
سيد عياش التدرج يكون عاده في حزب الله من
لديه صفه او عمل ضمن الدوائر الجهاديه
يعني ضمن ما يسمى بالهيكليه العسكريه
والامنيه هذا اولا هنا نعم نقول بموضوع
التدرج ضمن الوحدات التي ذكرت انما في ما
يخص السيد هاشم صفي الدين وطبعا انا اعرفه
معرفه شخصيه باقي القيادات
هو بالقصر من من الذين تفرغوا وسلكوا بل
اكثر من ذلك لديه باع طويل بالموضوع
الجهادي قبل السيد نصر الله لان السيد نصر
الله معروف كان في حركه امل في الوقت الذي
كان السيد هاشم صفي الدين وهو بالمناسبه
ابن خاله السيد حسن نصر الله يعني من نفس
العائله الواحده الامر الثاني عائله صفيه
الدين نحن نذكر بان المسؤول عن حزب الله
وارتباط حزب الله همم في ايران هو السيد
عبد الله صفي الدين يكون شقيق السيد هاشم
صفي الدين الامر الثالث نذكر بان ولد
السيد هاشم صفي الدين رضا قد تزوج من زينب
ابنه قاسم سليمان
الروابط الروابط السياسيه والدينيه
والجهاديه والامنيه والعسكريه والاداريه
وحتى الدبلوماسيه بين عائله
حسينيه في هذه المعايير التي عدتها
المساله للمتعلقه بالعمل المسلح العلاقات
علاقات المصاهره كذلك والعلاقه مع ايران
ايها تلعب دورا اكبر ام هنا يعني هو بشكل
مباشر هل يعني همم ايران راضيه بشكل اكبر
على هاشم صفي الدين ولذلك هو الاوفر حظا
في حال غاب نصر الله طبعا انا سوف انقل
يعني انقل عندما جاء السيد صفي الدين وانا
كنت موجود في عام 1989 جاء السيده
والشيخ نبيل معا لكن السيد هاشم صفي الدين
تدرج بالمسؤوليات التنظيميه داخل حزب الله
ونجح نجاحا باهرا بانه كان المسؤول عن
سوره التنفيذ في حزب الله فهو امام كل
الاختبارات اجتازها ونجحها وكان من الافضل
الاقرب
وقت ولكن يجب ان اعطي مجال للاستاذ احمد
عياش الرد اللي همم
ما رايك في ما قاله السيد الحسيني كذلك
اعتقد طبعا لن اختلف مع السيد الحسيني
فيما ذهب اليه لكن في نهايه المطاف عندما
يصل الى مرحله سيكون هناك مسؤول عن هذا
التنظيم عن هذه المنظمه التي هي تعتبر دره
في المشروع الايراني الخارجي
الامر ليس متعلقا الاطلاقا بنشات هذا
الشخص او ذلك يتعلق بنفوز ايران مباشره
يتحدث عن الحدث الثوري الايراني وانا
عندما قلت انه اتى من خلال التزكيه للحاله
الثوري الايراني ربما نحن نضيف ما ما ما
قاله السيد الحسين لكن نعطي الاهميه
للقرار
هو مساله انه ايران اراضي عنه وتريده هو
بالذات يعني بغض النظر عن المسائل الاخرى
التي ذكرها ضيفي الحسيني على العموم شكرا
جزيلا لكما همم ضيفه الكريمين الصحفي احمد
عياش كنت معنا من بيروت ومن المدينه
المنوره السيد محمد علي الامين العام
للمجلس الاسلامي العربي